[Music]
what I want to do today is tell you
about an area I've been working on
research wise for the last year or two
I'm a labor economist I study
I've studied things like why firms use
stock options and how graduating during
a recession affects the rest of your
career for if you're an mba class of 87
right yeah you guys are rich the guys a
year or two later they're out of luck
still still to this day but that's
another story what I want to talk to you
today about is the gig economy and as a
labor economist I'm very interested in
this I've been doing research using the
sorts of datasets labor economists use
all the time from the Census Bureau in
places like that but I've also been very
lucky to have some companies that handed
some gig economy companies that handed
over data and ask either asked me to do
some work with it or have opened
themselves up as laboratories that we
can study for research projects I'll
tell you a little bit about some of that
as we go along and then but mostly or at
least a good portion of what I want to
talk about is you guys are managers
you're business people I want to think
about well what does this mean to you as
managers what's the gig economy all
about strategic I teach strategy classes
here and I'm gonna at least spend a
little time thinking about what does
this have to do with the strategy of
your business so anybody who reads the
newspaper has heard a lot about the gig
economy uber all these other companies
and it probably has had a lot more
influence in the press than in the
actual real world but it is definitely a
growing part of our business and we as
labor economists want to understand it
going forward so to inspire the
discussion of the gig economy let me
tell you about three participants in the
gig economy this is a guy named Alexi I
love giving this talk because Alexi is
in the middle of Ukraine right now and
he has no idea that a hundred people or
however many here in Stanford are
looking at a picture and discussing him
but this is just a guy who does computer
software engineer he lives in a place in
the Ukraine that I certainly wouldn't
try to pronounce this is his this is his
profile on a website called up
upwork is the largest online freelancing
platform in the world this guy you can
hire him now to do some web development
for you or other things like that and he
will do it for you charge you $25 an
hour
he has great ratings he's done a lot of
work he's very successful he's selling
his work to people here in the United
States it's opened up an opportunity for
him to make money beyond his parent's
wildest dreams because they could only
sell their labor in the Ukraine they
couldn't sell it to Americans with a lot
more money to spend on it okay this is a
different guy a very different
perspective on the gig economy I don't
know his name he's in a newspaper
article in Bloomberg this guy lives up
in Sacramento he drives for uber at the
beginning of each week he drives down
from Sacramento to the Bay Area spends
four or five days in the Bay Area
driving 14 hours a day for uber spends
the night sleeping in the marina
San Francisco Marina Safeway parking lot
in his car now I don't know if you guys
are like me when you read a newspaper
article you feel like they leave out the
important parts they never explain what
he does about showering I'm dying to
know that but okay I'm the more
substantive issues he's making more
money because he comes to he comes to
the Bay Area to do his uber driving
instead of doing it up in Sacramento and
it's much more lucrative here he stays
busier the surge rates are higher all
sorts of stuff like that so both of
these guys are gig economy success
stories and what's interesting about
them is and this isn't true of the
entire gig economy is from a broader
labor economics perspective their
immigration stories the gig economy is
enhancing immigration how well what are
both of these people doing they're both
doing exactly what Americans I mean
sorry people have moved to the United
States have been doing for hundreds of
years
they're taking their Sir they're taking
their services selling them in the
United States and then taking at least
some of the money and sending it back
home now Aleksey doesn't even have to
move here to do that he's an image
upwork is an immigration platform just
as much as it is an actual work pace
workplace platform uber is less of an
immigration platform but it's
luckily the same story immigrant hit the
guy comes down from Sacramento works in
a higher wage area brings the money home
and his family is better off as a result
of it so those are kind of we're gonna
talk about other stories but those are
two perspectives let me tell you about a
third perspective on the gig economy
when I do a research project I like to
really get embedded in it so I've been
doing some driving for uber on the side
it doesn't pay very well so I'm probably
gonna stick with the whole Stanford
thing but but I have learned an
incredible amount about in the process
of it it's been very helpful for the
research project that I'm doing it's
it's been very interesting in many ways
there on the side you can I have a
really good rating I'm very proud of
that
[Applause]
someday I'm gonna find that guy who gave
me four stars and he's in trouble and
then the other thing to notice is you
don't see this as an uber rider on the
right that's the that's from the app for
the driver and that tells me those red
areas are the surge so that tells you
where you can go to make more money so
sometimes we'll be sitting around at
dinner and it drives my fiancee crazy
we'll just be sitting there now go
she'll go okay well what are we doing
you know after dinner I'll go look at
the search gotta go and okay
so what are we gonna talk about about
the gig economy she's actually in the
room and so but that's neither here nor
there so anyway these are the things I
want to cover pretty quickly here I want
to talk about some facts from the gig
economy segmenting the gig economy I
want to think about why it's grown and
then I want to tell you about a study
I'm briefly about the study I'm doing it
uber not about my own occurs what does
all this matter to you so I did a study
for up work up work asked me to use a
survey they conducted and their own data
to look at the gig economy and talk
about the state of the gig economy in
that paper I also looked at many other
studies of the gig economy and what's
interesting to note is the size of the
gig economy depends very much on how you
define it so when we say the gig economy
if you just mean people on gig platforms
like TaskRabbit that's a very small part
of the overall economy
in fact by one estimate one out of every
200 US workers have their primary job on
some sort of gig platform ten percent
have their primary job as some sort of
job that I would describe as a gig
economy job and what do I mean by that I
mean not just being on uber I mean being
an independent contractor being some
sort of you know moonlighter any
moonlighter sorry would not be your
primary job but being a freelancer and
something like that however that's a
small part of the overall gig economy
because most people who work in the gig
economy have another job they have a
regular job and they drive for uber on
the side even when I'm not driving for
uber I'm a member of the King economy
because once in a while I'll take on a
consulting project so I have a main job
and then I have an independent
contractor job so when you include those
people oh you're talking about 30% of
the US workforce has some sort of job
now this has been growing and because of
technology making it easier for people
to be free agents and other trends that
I'll talk about the size of the
independent workforce has grown
substantially in fact in a paper by some
other economists they estimated that
between 2005 and 2015 all of the growth
in the US labor force was in something
you might call the gig economy okay all
of the growth so they have regular
employment stayed steady in terms of
numbers and the growth was all in the
gig economy side this is a this is from
the paper I read I did for up work and I
don't want you to look at all the
numbers carefully don't worry about that
I just want to make the point that I in
that paper compared people who work in
the independent work force to all other
employees and the thing to notice if you
did have time to look through this slide
is that the independent work force those
who work in some way in the gig economy
are surprisingly representative of the
economy as a whole we think of
independent workers as sort of uber
drivers and temps and low-skilled
workers going from gig to gig actually a
lot of people at all skill levels are
members of the gig economy in one form
or another so you know so for example
the guy who miked me up I was talking to
him he's a employee for Stanford
halftime and then he's also in the gig
economy because he does gigs for various
other places around here where people
need to be miked up and other things
that have that same set of skills so you
know he's relatively skilled person a
lot of us who work in the gig economy
are you know there are unskilled people
as well so the distribution turns out to
be surprisingly similar whether you're
looking at the four people in the gig
economy two people in the broader
economy the other
thing is I get a little bit annoyed by
news accounts that equate working in the
gig economy with exploitation there's
kind of a feeling that oh we're just
gonna exploit these people who have
nothing to do but work on uber we have
lots of problems in the United States
with regards to low-level or low skilled
workers and you know there there's a lot
we need to do to address that I don't
think the gig economy is a process it
might be a little bit of an effect of
that I'll talk about that a result of
that but it's not driving it people that
work in the gig economy make less on a
per year basis but that's because
they're working fewer hours on a per
hour basis they actually make more and
by by my best estimates it's hard to say
exactly for various reasons my best
estimates are that per hour they make
15% more than those who have regular
jobs now they have to make more just to
break even because they have to pay
their own Social Security tax they don't
get benefits and things like that
but at least they're not being exploited
in a way that their pay is much lower
and in fact if you're working in the gig
economy by choice rather than because
you can't find a job that you want in a
regular employer you have even a higher
premium to working independently and
those they're most of the gig economy
are people who work there because they
want to not because they can't get a
real job or something like that and
that's especially true now if you ask
people in the gig economy in 2009 are
you working this gig job because you
want to or because you have to in 2009
when unemployment is 1012 percent the
answer is because I have to if you ask
them anybody who wants a job right now
can have one and so the people working
in the gig economy want to be working in
the gig economy and they are making a
premium relative to what they would be
earning for a similar people with
similar skills in the rest of the
economy so this is just some
distributions you can see the gig
economy workers are in green this is the
distribution this is I know it's been a
long time since you took data and
decisions here at the GSB this is a
distribution of hours per week by people
in the gig economy and the Green Line
and people in the regular in ray
traditional jobs in the red line you can
see that the distribution is much more
spread out for people in the gig economy
whereas they tend to be more sort of 40
hours or something close to that but so
that there's more flexibility and value
in that but the pay turns out to be very
similar overall there lumpiness in this
is a little because of the way the
survey set up I won't get into the
details but the point is that the pay is
pretty similar across the two groups
okay I did I've looked at a lot of
surveys of the gig economy of various
people being asked who work in the gig
economy why do you work in the gig
economy and I've taken all the answers
to these surveys thousands of answers
and I've I've done a really detailed
text analysis of this and I've got like
this fancy algorithm and text big data
algorithm to figure it out
and I took all my computing resources
available and I created the following
word cloud that really technically gets
at what people are looking for okay
that's it
if you ask somebody why do you work in
the gig economy it occasionally it's
because I have to I can't find the job
I'm looking for but in the majority of
cases they say I want the flexibility
flexibility comes in many dimensions it
can be I want to take this week off I
want to get my kids to school I want to
be able to do this and that but
flexibility really drives it and so
technologies enabled a lot of people to
become free agents to live much more
flexible work lives and so that's the
very positive side of the gig economy
now by the same token I could do the
same word cloud thing and say well what
don't you like about the gig economy and
again there there's just one answer
instability if I work in the gig economy
next week I might not get the guy in the
back who's doing my mic I have to say
nice things about him or he'll shut me
off he if he suddenly next week those
venues he's working out of a slow week
that's going to hit his earnings more
than other people and I you know that
can be problematic so I don't know about
him in particular but for a lot of gig
workers this is a bit of an issue for a
lot it's not
either they have a spouse who earns a
more steady income or they have enough
in savings that they can buffer those
things over a period of time so and in
fact I used I'm I was very careful to
use the word instability and not risk
I'm not convinced that it's higher risk
to work in the gig economy it's it's
more unstable month to month week to
week but the beauty of the gig economy
is the downsides are small if you have a
bad week or two you know you can bounce
back if the economy dips for a while you
lose 25% of your business
if you're in a regular job and the
economy dips there's a low probability
that you get hit with a very bad shock
which is to lose your job entirely so on
the total risk I'm not concerned that
worried about the gig economy workers
but from the variation it's definitely a
cost as it were of working in the gig
economy I teach a class here at the GSB
with a guy some of you may know
everybody in the Bay Area knows and
since your GSB alums you probably know
you may you may know him a guy named
Lenny Mendoza he and I teach a class
here on inequality in the United States
for MBAs and in that when you talk about
inequality a lot of people want to talk
about the gig economy as I mentioned cuz
they feel like it's people who are
exploited and it's not immediately
obvious that the gig economy is making
inequality worse I think it might be a
little bit of a outcome of inequality
but here I can give you just a little
sense for that so I already gave you a
sense for it with the uber driver the
uber driver is is smoothing out
inequality to some degree because he's
taking money from a rich area which is
the Bay Area and moving it back to
Sacramento that does that's a very smart
going a very small way to undoing some
of the some of the forces that are
leading to greater inequality United
States but on up work you see what's
going on there is it's also lowering
inequality but in a different way not
quite in the same way so these numbers
are again a little hard to see maybe but
let me just tell you what they say if I
go in the up work site so what is what
is the buyers on the up work site are
companies or small businesses
are looking for someone to do search
engine optimization work web development
work translation things like that if I
look at this zip code where those people
who are buying services are they're very
rich zip codes so to be a little more
specific the average income in the zip
code of a buyer on the upwork site it's
36 percent greater than the average
income for the United States as a whole
so these are rich zip codes they're also
even more outliers on things like
education the sellers on the other hand
are very middle-class incomes so for
example on the income side the average
income in a zip code of somebody who is
selling their services on up work is 15%
above the average in the United States
so it's up it's a little above middle of
Allah above the middle and so the point
is what is a site like up work doing for
inequality in the u.s. it's helping a
little it's taking money from rich
neighborhoods and pushing it to
middle-class neighborhoods it's not
doing anything for poor neighborhoods
nobody not nobody but relatively few
people from poor neighborhoods are
offering their services on up work
however we're a global school we were
happy to take a global perspective on
this up work is actually doing as does
immigration or trade of any immigration
and more broadly global trade does up
work is doing a fair amount to equalize
or to undo some inequality across the
world
why because guys like Alexi who come
from poor countries earn a lot more than
they otherwise would and they're getting
their money from rich countries an up
work there's just a ton of people doing
work in the Philippines in India that's
really bringing up the really having at
least on a one by one level if not
countrywide level helping a lot with
bringing up lower-class countries like
that
so the gig economy and in particular
globalizing it through sites like up
work has a potential to help undo
inequality on a small scale we're not
going to solve the problems that way by
any means but on a small scale it can
contribute when I think of inequality
and the gig economy here's the thing
where I think we have a
no problem and that's not these people
aren't even gig economy workers but they
get sort of treated like them they get
bunched in with them people who have
on-demand jobs this to me is a much
bigger problem
so the uber driver may not make a lot of
money the one on the left
she's an she's an uber driver she may
not make a ton of money but she makes a
decent living she has total flexibility
she works when she wants to
everything is at her just her choice so
in terms of whether she's contributing
to inequality I don't know but at least
she's earning money and we have to think
about the conditions of her life one of
the problems with technologies enabled
that flexibility for uber drivers it's
also enabled in flexibility how has it
done that Starbucks has gotten better
about this so it's a little unfair for
me to show you a Starbucks picture
because they've tried to undo this but a
lot of employers are getting much better
at figuring out their demand for workers
on a very short-term basis so they'll
call people the night before and say you
have to be here at nine o'clock tomorrow
that's very costly to a worker right so
the the uber driver has total
flexibility the person working at
Starbucks or whatever companies are
still doing this on-demand workers we
see a low wage in that job but if you
sort of thought of it in terms of
overall happiness of their job it's even
worse because the cost to them of these
jobs are very high they have to find
babysitters at the last minute they have
to do all sorts of other they have to do
other things so this I think is more of
a problem than than the other thing so
let me talk about one more thing related
to inequality and then and then I'll
move on to more managerial topics this
is a graph from a paper written by a
bunch of people one of the authors is
Nick Bloom who's my colleague here in
the Stanford Economics Department and so
what they did is so let me ask you
before I show you the graph if anybody
figured it out from that graph already
congratulations you were an RJ Miller
scholar probably and so what what I want
you to do is what I want you to think
about is the following do you think that
the increase in inequality we've seen in
United States over the last 30
is more because inequality has grown
within firms that as CEOs are making
more than line workers that difference
has grown within firms or do you think
it's more because across firms so the
CEO or the middle managers of one
company compared to the CEO is in the
middle managers of the other company
well it turns out it's entirely across
firms so that's what this graph was
showing you so if you look you can the
top let's just focus on the yellow line
at the top that shows you the percentage
increase in the top one percent of all
workers in the United States and the top
left up there it shows you the same
thing but done at a firm average level
so I take the top the average pay at the
top one percent paying firms and the
growth in those firms has been exactly
the same as the top for all workers in
individually so another way of thinking
about this is the inequality that you've
seen over the last thirty years is
because it Stanford
you know I've a Stanford professors have
had administrative assistants for that
whole time the multiplier between our
pay has been steady the whole 30 years
okay but if you look at if you compare
my pay to an economist at Foothill
College where the pay rates are lower my
salary has gone up quite a bit relative
to that other person why does that
matter
well why does that matter to the gig
economy what's happening is you see a
lot of big firms that are very
successful Apple Google you know
Stanford probably to some degree they're
very successful and they say okay every
you know are a lot more money we're
sharing it with everybody at the firm
why are why are we sharing it with
people who we you know why are we paying
a lot more to our food service workers
and to our janitors and those people get
shunted out of these companies so you
see a lot more outsourcing as we go over
time and as pay and pay disparities
between firms have grown and and firms
don't want to take the top the bottom
level with them as the salaries within
those firms grow so a lot of those
workers end up in the gig economy now
that doesn't mean they then become free
age
and they do okay but the point is that
part of what's made the gig economy grow
is this extension of inequality and
therefore wanting to make free agents
out of people who aren't core to the
business all right let me change gears
and talk about so I'm I'm giving a talk
at the Stanford GSB and nothing's
changed since you guys graduated looking
out at you what like ten years ago
something like that and so not much has
changed here at the GSB I am still
contractually obligated to show you a
two-by-two matrix in every talk that I
give so I followed through on that so I
like to segment the market for for
independent work along two dimensions
along the along the vertical axis I have
online versus offline the online part is
actually still a very small part of this
uber is huge as you know up works pretty
big you've heard of these companies but
there's still a ton of stuff that's just
done offline and this is where the
microphone guy Andy I think his name is
comes in he's still doing all these he's
doing this work for these other venues
where he puts on mics and does other
sound work at those places he gets those
gigs by contacts that call him at those
places he doesn't go on some website
that's all gonna move from right to left
that stuff will all get done online over
time that's just a matter of slowness
and technology taking over and old
networks working the way they are so we
know where that's going the ubers are
taking and that sort of thing is taking
over to me the more important issue is
the horizontal axis so I want to ask you
to go through to consider the following
thought experiment put yourself back in
the Year 2005 so I want you to forget
everything you've learned in the last 12
years now I know a lot of GSB students
and I know it's not hard for them to
forget things they've learned very
quickly so you I want you to go ahead
and do that so go back to 2005 and
suppose somebody came to you with the
following two options would you like to
invest in a company that's going to that
we want to build out into a big online
freelancing platform for software
developers and translators and things
like that
or would you like to invest in a company
that's going to enter the ride-sharing
business where people are gonna drive
each other around in their own cars and
I think if you're honest with yourself
you would say I'd go with the online
labor platform or upwork I wouldn't have
invested in uber well obviously you
would have been in hindsight we all
would have been wrong had we made that
decision and if you stop and think about
why it actually becomes apparent that
it's just simple economics or labor
economics and why would I say that well
what's going on an uber turns out to be
what I call commoditized matching in the
gig economy what does that mean it means
an uber is an uber uber sets you up with
somebody they tell you here's your match
the person shows up and they drive you
away and sure when I described it a
minute ago and you were fewer venture
capitalists that sounded funny their own
cars and all that
well whence people realize that you were
taking a product they knew really well
which was the taxi and you were doing it
better and cheaper it wasn't very hard
for them to say okay sign me up for that
and we all started driving around in
other people's cars very quickly so that
commoditized matching has very low
friction you just somebody in the middle
just to sign you you show up with the
car and off you go the key is the
intermediary the platform assigns your
car your driver and it all works very
well why have the likes of upwork and
cattle int which is a place to match
MBAs to gig type consulting projects why
have those been slower to to catch on
because there's a lot more friction in
the labor market if all I do is
introduce you these sites introduce you
to a set of people and then you have to
go through all the trouble of vetting
them negotiating with them figuring out
who's who and what not so what you've
done is instead of taking something we
all understand which is the taxi and
making it better and cheaper you've
taken something we all understand which
is hiring people and you've made it
difficult and weird and different than
it used to be and it's not worse over
time we're going to get there we're
going to learn how to hire online and
we're gonna get better at distance
learning at distance hiring but it's
going to be slower and it may
not take over the market for employees
in the same way that lyft and uber have
completely taken over the market for
taxis so why would you ever employ
somebody from the gig economy well the
big advantages are one is what I call
labor arbitrage if you can have somebody
in the Ukraine do a job instead of
somebody in Silicon Valley saves you a
lot of money so obviously you want to do
that choice I'm going to come back to in
a minute faster onboarding but the
bottom two a lot of you have small
companies out there and I would tell you
that you guys should be more on the
forefront than the big companies in
hiring gig workers why because the fact
that hiring gig workers makes it easier
for you to downsize or reget or change
the workers the workforce skill you have
and the fact that you can hire partial
workers you only need a half of an SEO
specialist you can do that through the
gig economy hiring regular workers you
don't have these same sorts of
advantages and so the ability to be much
more nimble being a lot of you have
startups every one of you has done four
pivots in the front end in the process
of running your business and therefore
you need a different set of skills
having more flexible gig workers for a
lot of those jobs not for all of them
but for a lot of those jobs makes those
pivots a lot easier you can get rid of
people you don't need anymore
bring on people you do and you can hire
people for partial jobs if you happen to
be a gig platform this means that small
companies are a big growth opportunity
for you because if you get into current
startups
they're the ones who if they get the the
thing that's keeping big companies from
from figuring out how to solve those
frictions I was talking about it's just
there they're stuck in their old ways
but smaller companies as they scale are
gonna be much better at breaking down
that friction hiring remotely and doing
all the things that will make the gig
economy bigger so if you have a gig
platform this is a big growth
opportunity get in on the startups now
and as they scale and need more people
they will remain able to take advantage
of the advantages you have to offer
I mentioned that I would tell you about
choice what's another really good thing
about the gig economy is it just opens
up the possibilities to you
so Alexi and other people like him not
only are they cheaper but they deepen
the pool of potential software
developers dramatically here in Silicon
Valley that's not such a big deal this
cost savings are a big deal we have
plenty of software engineers around but
in a lot of places suppose you were you
know suppose you were in Chicago or a
better thing would be suppose you were
in Lawrence Kansas a town of 25,000
people with a few hundred software
developers well you're kind of hiring
off that boardwalk over there so you're
there's all these software engineers if
you think of all the potential people
you could hire as spreading out along a
boardwalk and the people right in the
middle are perfect for you and at one
end are those who don't have quite the
right skills for one reason at the other
right skills for another where do you
want to be hiring from you want to be
hiring from a very crowded boardwalk and
if you live in Silicon Valley just every
you just walk out the door and there's a
ton of software engineers and there's
plenty who will fit the exact need you
need find getting them to come work for
you as a difficult problem but at least
there will be plenty available but if
you're in Lawrence Kansas there's
nothing out there so what do you do well
this is a picture from upwork if you if
you only want to hire in your area of
course you just have the people who are
in your area but if you were in Chicago
or Lawrence Kansas or wherever you are
you suddenly have 20,000 additional
software developers available to you who
are thousands and thousands of miles
away so if you're in a smaller area or
even in Chicago which doesn't quite have
as thick a market for software engineers
the these online these online platforms
provide a much thicker a much more
crowded boardwalk for you and there's a
lot of value in that now you have to
read you have to change the way you hire
people and the way you work people into
your company but it's something that at
least creates a lot of value for you I
want to change gears slightly for about
five minutes and then spend my last five
minutes before I take questions talking
about strategies Claudia Goldin is a
Harvard economist best probably the
leading authority in economics on
male-female pay differentials and she
said the converging roles of men and
among the grandest advances in society
and the economy in the last century
women have really caught up in the
workplace is what that means I'm trans
I'm gonna translate once in a while and
so what she says is that the gender gap
in pay would be considerably reduced and
might vanish altogether if firms did not
have an ascent ofor tional reward
individuals who labored long hours and
worked particular hours and so there's
another word in there she mentions that
jobs are structured and remunerated to
enhance temporal flexibility if you make
the job more flexible women will do
better was the underlying hypothesis of
this and many other predictions about
the gig economy so that's what we're
studying at uber we went into Oberer and
we said ok well there's no
discrimination here the algorithm is
gender blind and so women and men are
gonna make the same here right well it
doesn't turn out to be that simple this
is pay on uber or per hour
these are hourly earnings for uber
drivers over the last couple of years
and what you can see is there's a pretty
steady 5 a pretty steady 5% pay gap
between them men driving for uber make
about a dollar an hour or about 5
percent more than women driving for uber
ok
now I'm not gonna call call anybody
because you know it's reunions you're
you're just here to have fun but anybody
want to take a guess as to why why do
men make more
I do not have a good direct test of that
hypothesis she said for those of you who
are in the air out there I'm supposed to
be using microphones but these will be
quick answers she said bathroom breaks
to my knowledge that is not the answer
by the way as an uber driver and a man I
could say if that's true I'm not
contributing to the male differential
but that's another story
men drive faster was the next guess
that's one of them got another one
okay men are more responsive to making
more money it's not that they drive more
to the surge areas it's that they work
more when there is Sir John whereas
women want to work when their kids are
in school when whatever it is okay one
more reason anybody know one more reason
exactly right
yep okay but there's a third reason ah
that's kind of I'll come back to that in
a second let me show you the answer it's
not tip somebody said tips this is all
before
uber had tips and I have not yet gotten
a tip so as far as I can tell that's not
that relevant so it's a little bit we
wrote this paper we started writing this
paper purely expecting it to be the
thing about men Drive when it's are
willing to drive when it's less safe
they'll drive on the weekends when
people are more likely to puke in your
car I had some graphics for that I took
them out and we thought it was gonna be
more about this work while your kids are
in school thing that's a very small part
of it this is the entire hundred sixty
eight hours of the week from midnight on
Sunday to the next Sunday at midnight
and this is what fraction of each hour
of their time are being driven by men
versus women if you look at this
carefully and I won't go in there's a
little bit of a difference where men are
driving the dangerous hours and women
are driving more during school hours but
that turns out to explain a very small
part of the wage gap then you got the
third explanation I'll come back to
speed the second one
nobody mentioned is it turns out and
this is true of other labor markets one
of the innocuous non-discriminatory
reasons while you can tell a
discrimination story but one of the
reasons men make more in a lot of labor
markets holds on uber to it's that they
work more and you learn on the job and
get better at it the average man on uber
is driven I don't know I'll make up a
number a thousand trips the average
woman driver on uber has only driven 500
turns out this is earnings per this is
the average earnings for your first trip
up to the average earnings for your five
thousandth trip and you could see
there's quite a bit of a learning curve
among other things you learn where the
quick in-and-out bathrooms are and other
things along those line and then finally
there's the other answer that men just
drive faster so what does this tell you
this is now this is truly from data and
decisions that's the bail distribution
of driving speed and the blue which is
men is out and to the right that means
for those of you didn't do well in D&D
that means that they drive faster okay
so what does this tell us it tells us
that uber and the gig economy provide
flexibility but that while that's that
can be the great equalizer in terms of
utility and in terms of making your life
easier if you're a woman it's not gonna
be the great equalizer on a per hour of
work dollar basis it does flexibility
doesn't necessarily get rewarded in the
labor market and at uber and at other
places we see that so as a result the
women who drive on uber and work and
other gig sites are very happy for the
flexibility but they don't necessarily
get it's not changing the wage premium
in a way that that undoes the biases
that come from certain attributes of our
labor market so let me spend the last
few minutes talking about as managers
what does any of this mean to you well
these are the things all of you who
employ people know that those are the
key components of your labor costs so
how does the gig economy help you well
one way it can help you is you can just
move your money you can move your
employees from Denver to the Ukraine if
you can offshore them and that's what
called labor arbitrage another thing is
if you just have if you just want to
ramp up a job quickly getting somebody
in through the gig economy can be very
very quickly done and very economically
done and that lowers the amount of
vacancies and it lowers your hiring
costs all of which as you know can be
very expensive if you're a startup you
don't want to hire somebody who you
don't have enough work for so if you
hire a part of person through the gig
economy that can pay off very well but
the problem is your hire a group of
people who are by definition transient
these people are leaving anytime they
want to they're free agents that's what
they value so using them strategically
can be very beneficial but you have to
think of it as very only those parts of
your business where you want to be
transactional so I've talked about data
and decisions in other classes let me
remind you of your course strategy class
I'm gonna skip this slide come remember
your business if your business is
successful it's because you have a
competitive advantage right if you run a
business say to yourself what is my
competitive advantage what do I have in
the way of a capability resource or
position that's unusual that's hard for
other people to get and if you don't
have a good answer to that question by
the way you should start looking at a
new business model but if you do have an
answer to that question often it can
come down to I have certain capabilities
that are invested in certain people well
if that's true you don't want to go too
far on this whole gig economy
transactional thing because those people
are not your company is entired into the
gig economy they cannot by definition be
part of your competitive advantage ok
I'm going to skip the example of Walmart
and and whether people can be a
competitive advantage because I just
want to point out competitive advantage
is about differentiation independent
workforce is about undifferentiated very
transactional commoditized labor markets
you should not be hiring any work
through any sort of gig economy type
arrangement if that job involves
creating or maintaining your competitive
advantage you should be doing it because
of labor arbitrage because you need a
skill temporarily to scale up or down
quickly but you should certainly not be
doing it you should absolutely stop
before hiring someone through a gig
economy job and say is this something I
need is this something that sets me
apart or another way of doing it I like
to I usually don't like sort of five
things you can do to change your
business type type things but I will
want to I do want to leave you with a
checklist before you go hire somebody
off the gig economy ask yourself can I
get this same skill cheaper and further
away in which case you do maybe want to
think about going into the gig economy
ask yourself is it okay if the person is
in here very long and if the answer is
no you definitely don't want to go into
the free-agent world if the gig economy
is there a good chance I'm gonna want to
get rid of this person do they have some
specialized skill not because they're
bad or something but because my needs
will change does this person have a
specialized skill in that case sure free
agents are good if they come in and give
you some skill you need and that
everybody else needs as well do I just
want part of a person that's when the
gig economy can make a lot of sense and
am I looking for a skill that's very
scarce and that I'm like others just
need some of the time and it doesn't set
me apart then sure you want to go
through the gig economy so let me just
wrap up and then I'll be happy to stay
and discuss questions about this or
online dating or anything you want to
talk about so far the impact of the gig
economy has actually been pretty small
if you read the New York Times in The
Wall Street Journal or if you do what I
did I went to a conference recently for
temporary help work and spoke they're
there they don't think the impact is
small but if you look in broadly in the
economy the impact of the gig economy is
still pretty small but it's growing and
it's growing pretty quickly and the
reason for that is a lot of it can make
the economy run more more efficiently
and technologies allowing it to be more
and more that way a lot of people have
preferences for flexibility that are
enhanced nicely by it there's a lot of
potential downsides
Atilla TI shoulda said risk I told you I
wouldn't say that but volatility people
feel like they're second-class status
and you know whether or not there's in
it inequality issues is a different
question but I think as managers you
should think especially if you're at a
small company about the strategic ways
you can use this strategically and if
you're small and growing you might think
about building in a comparative
advantage relative to some of your big
competitors a comparative advantage
around being able to be very flexible
and to quickly up and down scale and
bring on skills that other companies can
so with that I'm gonna leave you that's
my twitter handle where you know with
this room I could easily improve my
followers by about 17 times so go sign
up and thank you very much I'd be happy
to take some questions
I am told I am told that it's very
important that you wait for a microphone
before you speak because our audience at
home wants to be able to hear you
somebody Houston is as follows when
you've put up that slide originally
showing that I think it's 15% of the
economy is going gig so to speak the
first thing that run through my head was
what's gonna happen in 20 years 30 years
when all these people don't have health
care yeah so that's a really good
question a lot of so the as the gig
economy grows there have to be some
public policy reactions to it I would
argue as an economist that on the list
of issues we have to deal with in
healthcare the role of the gig economy
is about thirty-eighth on that list so
I'm not that worried about that just
because I think we have to do so many
things with regards to health care over
the next 10 years that its effect on the
gig economy is just another of the many
issues that it has I absolutely agree I
mean the exchanges and whatnot would
obviously go that's how people are
dealing with it the other way they're
dealing with it is a lot of gig workers
have spouses with health insurance so
those are the two ways we're dealing
with it now as this grows you're
absolutely right but you know just
there's so many other it's I mean I
don't want to talk about health care
because we'll get sort of depressed and
whatnot next who's got the mic nobody up
there I love the people who like they
come back and they're like I'm at
reunion I got to sit in the Skydeck no
matter what but we don't have any mics
up there so one question will this at
some point have repercussions also for
what I would call very skilled workers
so let's say ahead of growth a senior
director and product management a chief
marketing officer who says you know what
I actually just want to do two or three
at the same time but at scale and as
sort of the lateral question to that
would we then see something that goes
even beyond this individual engagement
and assignment where these people will
start bringing many teams depending on
what they need with them and serve we
will have a little bit
modification of work right where you
have these micro masses of enterprises
or or small enterprises playing
everything you just described already
exists in at least experimental form so
let me tell you two company names I I
don't mean to shill for anybody here but
two companies I happen to have been
introduced to recently that are going
down this line exactly one is just
called top Tao you can figure out the
derivation of that name hopefully and
they're just putting together they're
just looking at free agents people who
want to earn the kinds of money that you
would work to make as a software
engineer at a company but they just want
to work independently either from home
or whatever and they want either one
temporary gig or a bunch at one time and
they're making more money than they can
make as employees and they really like
it now they can't work on the most
exciting thing happening it can't quite
be topped out if what I said was right
about competitive advantage it can't
quite be top-down it has to be really
high Tao but not quite top tell and
reason for that is the top guys have to
be your competitive advantage if they're
not if the guy on the web at top towel
is your competitive advantage it's not
going to work but business models very
close to what you're talking about exist
another company out there is called
business Talent Group I believe and they
want to their claim is that they're
going to disrupt Mackenzie so they're
trying to put together virtual teams
from around the world that will work on
projects or they are and you know
they'll just grow over the internet so
those those things are happening that I
wouldn't say anybody's really
I wouldn't say anybody's really nailed
that business model yet but they're
they're trying and it'll happen who has
them does some anybody have a mic so
what's the difference between
outsourcing and the second category of
your gig economy which was the second
category of my gig economy I
you had the upper one in the lower one
so the guy this the guy in in Europe oh
what's the difference between
outsourcing and that it is that's
outsourcing
yeah outsourcing your and outsourcing
element right an outsourcing has been
around for 30 years
agreed so the difference is it's growing
the gig economy is about growing
outsourcing the like I said people have
been doing independent work for time and
Memoriam this is just a matter of
technologies make it easier than it ever
was and it's just growing a part of the
business the other big difference is
here's one other big difference in the
old days you outsource to a company you
still do that a lot we outsource to a
food service company but you now we also
outsource to individuals like Alexi for
individual projects that you didn't do
in the old days because it just wasn't
as easy to find those people you did
some of it of course but the the ease
with which it's done has grown and will
grow more that matching process will get
better and better yes thank you
part of the reason people go to work is
not only for the salary direction every
bit it's what you call the benefits on
the side which can be very substantial
unemployment benefit health cover and so
on and so and so on the gig economy
takes that away from people right I
suspect I you you are basically creating
or you're talking about creating in a
society where everybody is at risk every
day for the rest of their life on no
social safety net protection whatsoever
wow that was kind of a downer way of
putting it but
but it's totally it's totally fair
question
I I I agree so how we're the under this
comes back to your question about health
care from a public policy perspective so
there's two ways to look at the gig
economy I would argue actually use the
word safety net I love that term the gig
economy is in many ways an alternative
safety net if you lose your job and you
don't have all the benefits they used to
have at least you can go drive for uber
to make a little bit of money and it's
better than just taking unemployment now
having said that all those other
benefits don't get made up for and from
a public policy perspective we're gonna
have to make those we're gonna have to
make it easier for people to be able to
get those benefits on their own either
by buying health care in whatever you
know you can already the retirement
stuff is pretty easy now already you can
go get the equivalent of a 401k plan
self-employment 401k plan and things
like that but absolutely I mean
especially in the United States we've
always had sort of a free agent the
safety net hasn't been that great and
it's not this is not going to make it
any any better I agree with that you
haven't spoken about any form of
employee rights in the end you can be
cheated you can be treated unfairly and
so on this gig economy is completely
devoid of that in Europe there is a huge
pushback against this right now and I
think you know you need to address that
because I felt your talk was very much
on on one side of the argument I don't
think there was balance in what you
presented so I'd like you to balance it
now
so let me let me address that in two
ways one is again if you ask most people
why do you work in the gig economy they
say it's because they want to so do they
feel exploited no if you ask an uber
driver does uber treat you will know if
you ask a taxi drop or somebody else who
makes that much money and works for a
company do you feel exploited there
probably as likely to say yes as if they
don't work for uber
so keeping minimising exploitation in
the labor market is very very important
I
hundred percent agree I haven't seen a
lot of evidence yet that the
exploitation I'm you know the the people
who don't make much money in the United
States are getting a raw deal right now
I'm happy to say that and in agreement
with that you'd be hard-pressed not to
agree with that I don't think it's any
worse if you're in the gig economy than
if you make similar amounts of money and
work for a company you are a little
there art I'm not gonna say there aren't
situations like that certainly some gig
companies won't pay people or will do
something wrong but they'll be thrown
off the platforms or other ways that
that happen just as quickly so am i
sympathetic to the difficulties of
low-skilled workers the United States
right now absolutely do I think the gig
economy is any worse in that way than
employers I don't actually think so I
haven't seen any evidence to suggest
that's the case do you see any
developments that could happen that
would stop the growth of the gig economy
policy implication
policy policy things you know people
were talking about various things
they're trying the various sort of
crackdowns on the gig economy in Europe
where I think the growth has actually
been just as good and I mean in some
ways in a place like Europe where where
policies tend to be more Pro employee
friendly on the one hand there's
pushback against the gig economy on the
other hand the employers are pushing
more and more for it because anything
they can do to take someone on who's not
an employee that they can later get rid
of
is is gonna make the gig economy look
better so that could go either way but
policy implemented
he's the senator most involved in the
policy side of the gig economy right now
and I think he's done some interesting
things and taken some interesting steps
in that direction I my view is we need
to go slowly because there's always
unintended consequences so you want to
allow the people who thrive in the gig
economy to continue to thrive there you
don't want to put the brakes on them but
to the extent that anybody is getting
exploited you want policy to to avoid
that and so we want to balance these
things and take it somewhat slower you
know mark Warner's not getting far on
this I don't know if anybody's noticed
there's one or two other things going on
in Washington these days so the gig
economy isn't quite front and center but
going forward the thing that can really
stop the growth of this is if policies
made made it so that even people were
it's a very good idea stop doing it yeah
speaking of impacts on the gig economy
do you have any thoughts on automation
of the gig economy self-driving cars
machine learning algorithms taking over
white-collar labor
yeah so people seem to equate the gig
economy with robots taking over and
these are two things the I don't equate
them but I do see why that happens
because they're both driven by technical
changes easing these things so it's a
separate somewhat separate question that
we you know John mentioned that a lot of
people in Stanford generally are really
worried about this I spent this morning
up at the Center for the Advanced Study
in the behavioral science Sciences on a
big cross campus project we're doing
trying to think about the effects of
autonomous vehicles on the economy we
haven't started worrying about the gig
economy's role in all of that but that's
a really big question I can give you my
own view really quickly but that's you
know it's want it you could if you've
chose a different labor economist you
get a different story I'm less worried
than everybody else is about the robots
putting us all out of work they're gonna
put a lot of people sorry real quickly
they're gonna put a lot of people out of
work but if you go back in history 200
years ago we were all farmers
nobody's a farmer anymore and we still
have jobs now everybody says this time
could be different and someday they're
gonna be right when they say this and so
I wish this wasn't on camera because you
can make me look silly in ten years but
I think I'm less worried about that than
a lot of people aren't yeah last
question I'm curious if you've done any
look at the impact on organizations that
are dependent on employees for example
workers compensation insurance company's
401k providers group benefits how fast
is is going to happen how quickly do
they need to begin responding I think
the answer is it's happening it's not
happening so fast that it's like a
threat and whatnot but those companies
I've talked to a lot of them at
conferences and stuff and they are all
worried about it and out in front of it
and trying to do something about it and
I think they should be and I think
that's great you should all be out in
front of the trends in your market you
all know that you went to the GSB you've
gotten this far because you've been
ahead of the trends in your market but
absolutely this is not just about gig
economy it's about the whole
infrastructure behind employee benefits
and all sorts of things thank you so
much for coming today enjoy your weekend
and hope to see you
[Applause]
[Music]